god damn look at that [ __ ]
[Music]
what's up i'm mike feeney and i'm here
to answer the internet would you rather
always have the hiccups or always have a
headache when you have the hiccups
there's people scaring you or telling it
that's the worst part of that eat some
peanut butter
that's that's the worst part [ __ ]
hiccups because people are always trying
to give you like fun suggest stand on
your head hold your breath [ __ ] off i'll
just let me let me my what is it like
your diaphragm is jumping or something
yeah yeah it's going to course correct
at some point would you count to 1
million for 1 million dollars you are
locked in an empty room until you're
finished yeah of course but is it one of
those things where if i mess up
yeah if i mess with start over i mean
that might be probably that might be
like something that we can do to
terrorists you know what i mean as a
form of torture be like we get we'll let
you right at it you can leave guantanamo
you just gotta count to a million and
then at like 793 000 they get the
hiccups and go wait what was it and then
they start over again i'd be like kill
me now
kill me i don't think you can mess up
once i think that's either you do it all
the way through or you give up because i
mean less if yeah if you mess up in like
within the first like you know 500
seconds but once you're up to like in
the thousands and certainly into the
hundreds of thousands to start that over
is a killer it's demoralizing and also
how long would it take to count to a
million if you never i mean it has to
take a day maybe you know like it seems
longer i would say a million seconds is
gonna be like uh like a week
that's so crazy to just sit there and
just be sleep deprived
11 straight days a million dollars by
the way gets you nothing anymore a
million dollars is like that's bus fare
and two sandwiches in new york city okay
you have to choose three animals to
start a zoo who are you choosing i love
this all right right away you gotta go
you gotta go with like a lion something
you know king the king i wanna get apex
predators you know i want to throw a
shark in there somewhere if it's some
sort of zoo aquarium hybrid kind of a
thing maybe where i can put the tank of
the shark right next to the lion thing
and see if who who's gonna out alpha one
another i also don't think monkeys are
necessary people love to go to monkeys
and love them in jews the monkeys get a
lot of activity they're swinging and
jumping and they also do the thing where
they mimic you at the [ __ ] they mimic
they throw their [ __ ] they jerk off at
you i kinda like monkeys i gotta look
uh but i want something that's like
danger like a [ __ ] hippo or like
something that's gonna be like people go
uh hippo who cares about hippo and then
they run and trample six children you
know what's so weird about hippos it's
because of our childhood because of
hungry hungry hippos we were like oh
they're playful they just want to eat
and you're like no they're like
cold-blooded murderers and they don't
even have like a lot of teeth they have
like two they have like two or three big
teeth and you go where are your teeth
and how you how are you you're just
gumming it but then straw strength it's
just
god damn i might do i love a hippo would
you put your kid in a gorilla pit for 50
000
listen i don't i don't have a kid but if
you said what i put my dog in a gorilla
pit for 50 000 you can't you can't do
that unless you're trying to
kill your kid unless you can put him in
one of those like diver tanks it would
be fun to be like if the kid did
something like if he didn't clean his
room once and you're like well you know
the rules and then you just drop them in
with coco the gorilla and hope that he
doesn't get ripped apart because if he
gets out of that he's going to be a
different child you know in a good i'm
[ __ ] putting the kid in the bed i
don't even need the money i just wanted
for a well-behaved child because after
that i'll be like you know he's like i
didn't eat all my green beans and you go
hmm and then all of a sudden he's like
should you lock a dog out of the room
when you're having sex yeah i mean
listen unless that's like a thing you're
into you know what i mean unless that's
like you want like the dog maybe it's
just the power you know of being like
dominance assert dominance in your thing
i try to lock the dog my dog will try
and scratch at the thing and i'm like i
can't i can't let you in here man it's
just it's too distracting what if he
jumps on the bed when you're in like me
like things you know licking things i
mean you know especially yeah if the dog
starts licking my ass what if i like it
you know like that now he's gonna be a
part of it every time
that's what i wouldn't do it because i'm
afraid i'd love it how about that
would you rather a throw up any time
someone says mcdonald's or b wear a
fedora for the rest of your life and if
anybody asks you about it you have to
say i like the way it looks
there's so many mcdonald's everywhere
and it's such a every language in every
world they just go mcdonald's like you
can't get away from the world
everywhere you know put a fedora i think
i would go throw up any time someone
says mcdonald's and then just come up
with a great story about it and they're
like why'd you just throw up i'm like
sorry every time i think about that i
think about the time i was like eating
this girl out on the fryer grease and
then she fell into the pit and then i
kept going because i wanted her to come
you know and then you just and you just
do that and then people go oh okay you
know and then they just don't bring it
up around you so i'm going with a uh
would you rather give up a one inch of
your dick for six inches of height or
vice versa so or give up one inch of
height for six inches of dick here's the
thing both aren't gonna benefit me
enough six inches of height you could
give up an into your height no problem i
would give up it you'd have a [ __ ]
hammer but then what am i doing with
that that's so
that's so much awesome first off it's
like having a dick that big becomes
maintenance at that point we are like i
don't know what you're starting with
well i mean when you're starting with an
irish dick you know it's pretty great
you know uh it's not long but it's thin
i'm not interested in the in the in the
12-inch 14-inch hammer and i also don't
unless i would actually take an inch off
my dick how about that i would take an
inch off my dick to gain six inches of
height and then just be in the nba i
guess because then i'm in if i'm not in
the nba at least then i look like
somebody who's in the nba how about
how many inches of height would you give
up
to just
have your perfect dick oh that's good i
wouldn't know what you prefer or what
you're starting with what you end with
but you could be like i wanted to be
seven and three quarter seven and a half
with this much girth and i would
definitely
i would add girth i would i would go
soda can level girth how about that just
an unreasonable amount of girth where
it's like a fire hose they were just
there's just no functionality to it
whatsoever but people go like god damn
look at that [ __ ] you know i would give
up like two i would still want to be at
least six foot i give up two inches
would you be in the fives no no there's
not i would i would perfect it i would
cut my dick off before i become
five foot anything you short little
dweebs would you have sex with a dead
person for five minutes if you'd get
your laundry done and folded magically
for the rest of your life
now here's the will people know that i
had sex with a dead person yes yes
then still yes because i do the drop off
laundry now which by the way is like the
great i don't know if anybody ever told
you about drop-off laundry it cost like
four dollars more than doing it yourself
yes it's it's the most cost-effective
thing in the world laundry mats you
could charge whatever you want we'll pay
it we'll pay it i just i feel like if
you're gonna [ __ ] a dead person you know
there's there's a level to it where i
feel like you got to mentally get there
you know what i'm saying where you're
like i'm just going to go i'm not going
to look at the face i'm just going to go
i'm just going to go in there put myself
in a different location for a bit and
then but here's the thing it's not only
just that it's to have them to have them
folded perfectly too like i take out the
shirt and now there's no there's no
crease or wrinkle and i just it's a
throw on and go
that perfect little thing i mean it's
yeah yeah i will [ __ ] my people who do
my laundry after they're dead as a thank
you for their service how about that
would you rather be able to have sex
with any five people for a year or get
to powerbomb whoever you want whatever
you want for a year i think i gotta
choose
five people to have sex with because the
power bomb is fun
two or three times but if you get to
tell me that for a year i get like
rihanna on speed dial and be like come
on over a bit that's when i'd start
that's when i'd start experimenting i'd
be like hey leo you know like i'll
i'll see if i get to for a year i'll go
to st bart's on a yacht and just kind of
see what it's like chest that dad bought
out myself you know
but that would be great just like margot
robbie have a whole have a whole gang of
people and then just one guy who like
shouldn't be in that sex it'd be like
alec baldwin now you know like with the
ptsd and just a big basset hound head
you know they're like why is alec
baldwin and i'm like he believe me he
does something for me you know if you
could pick one other body part of your
body that you could use to orgasm what
would it be now does that mean [ __ ] is
gonna come out of there or i just let's
do that you ever do that thing you get
that that you put on the top of your
head and you it like scratches it and
you get that little kind of a thing how
cool would it be if you just start
coming out of the top of your head like
a bellagio fountain you know what i mean
you can't fake it and it would look
great yeah if you get a whole like
yes
a fondue fountain of cup and it just
starts coming out everyone's excited the
girl knows that she did a great job the
music syncs up to it perfectly every
single time it happens every 10 to 15
minutes
again oh yeah i am just giving myself a
[ __ ] [ __ ] aren't i every single
time here's the thing i feel like i
might be able to come from getting my
back scratched like i don't know why
there aren't like backs there's massage
parlors there should be back scratch
parlors where you just go get lightly
scratched you know if you want shiatsu
that's as much foreplay as i'll ever
need would you rather a have a flock of
geese swarm you every time you fart or
never use a phone or computer again
i think the having geese swarm to you
would be such a great way of getting
your anger out because everybody hates
geese anybody who likes a
goose has never seen them angry because
they're they're vicious they [ __ ]
everywhere they're they're terrible
creatures that we should take away from
the earth but if if you told me that
every time i i like have mexican food i
just [ __ ] load up with a bat and i
just sit there and just [ __ ] and then
they come flying in and i just start
teeing off on them
that's a great i never heard that answer
that would be real just to really club
them to death and then i can hang them
upside down sell them to chinese
restaurants i don't know well then
there's a business in this you know yeah
yeah
i'm gonna start an instagram account
with my phone and computer about me
just the guy who kills geese like just
unapologetically bludgeons geese to
i'm gonna make a billion dollars doing
that
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon